je suis parti parce qu'elle selon moi
alors vraiment en a fait une priorité
tu es si pour la maison boulot parce
qu'on veut changer les choses parce que
c'est
ici c'est pour le futur un mouvement de
mobilisation pour le climat initiée par
les élèves du secondaire qui viennent de
différentes écoles vendredi soir assis
en rond il recrute de nouveaux membres
en fait père et fille née dans un
sentiment de rage et de colère et
d'injustice
elle si sarah c'est elle qui était
derrière les vendredis de grève le
printemps dernier
albert aussi est là depuis le début
demande parce que l'école est important
on utiliser l'école comme levier pour
montrer notre désespoir
le combat pour le climat c'est devenu
toute leur vie cet été avec les à une
porte-parole au niveau universitaire il
préparait la reprise de cette
mobilisation
dans ces petites 100 lâche celle arrêtée
parce que c'est la fin du monde a été
arrêté ce n'est pas une option et la
grève pour le climat le 27 septembre ne
sera pas la fin non plus et je vois pas
ça comme une finalité je pense qu'il
faut qu'on compense cette stratégie a
beaucoup plus long terme pour les
changements finalement plus structuraux
qu'on veut dans notre société aussi
ils ne sont pas les seuls à se mobiliser
le 26 ou dans les bureaux de la csn
groupes environnementaux communautaire
et étudiants se préparent aussi à cette
grève qu'ils annoncent déjà historique
une histoire qui s'inscrit dans un
mouvement mondial mais qui se veut aussi
la continuité du printemps érables de
2012 j'avais beau à voir comment oses en
2012 je vois vraiment ce qu'on fait
comme la suite logique de ce qui s'est
passé on construit sur les mêmes bases
puis finalement c'était la hausse des
frais de scolarité mais mais les
changements climatiques ce soit puisque
ça va faire s'est exacerbé les
inégalités justice sociale il s'estime
apte et sinon le combat et comme en 2012
les critiques fusent de toutes parts m'a
dit que j'étais une terroriste que je me
fait pleurer les gens j'aime bien il a
écouté et je ne perds pas à cause de moi
minc aux estimations à quel moment on ne
peut non plus les canassons la verte
juste à dire qu'on est des produits
notre système n'est produit notre
société on est habité par les systèmes
qui voilà enfin on fait notre possible
sauf qu on me dit difficile à l'essai
mais on peut pas on peut pas en sortir
jean kissi justement pour ce malgré ces
critiques
ils sont prêts pour la prochaine
bataille
[Musique]
ici jacques ory charbonneau raid au
canada mon frère